- You got a phone?
(crowd cheering)
- [Man In Blue Shirt] Picture?
- Video.
Victoria, hey it's Gary V.
I'm giving a speech to
two thousand people.
(crowd cheering)
(upbeat tempo music)
Listen to me, I'm here with your fiance,
fiance right?
- Yeah
(screeching)
- Fiance?
Pretty good looking dude.
(crowd laughing)
Um, anyway,
just keep listening.
I promise you,
it's not because I want
you to listen to me,
it's because what I'm
talking about is universal.
People long before me
were talking about it too.
Life is very basic.
The second you stop hearing that,
both positive and negative,
is the second your life gets happier and
the fact that you're starting to get
happier means the world to me
and I hope this video
is something you play
over and over anytime your old friend or
some random person on the internet
makes you feel bad.
You send them this video.
Hey, person.
Fuck you!
(crowd cheers)
- [Group] Hey!
- [Gary Voiceover] You've
got your perspective.
(click)
(airplane engine roaring)
(crowd cheering)
I just want to be happy.
Don't you want to be happy?
(upbeat tempo music)
- In 2009 when I started
making business content,
more than half of the comments that I got,
were for me not to talk
about business because
I should..
- That's you're livelihood.
- ...because I should
only stick to wine because
that's what I know.
- Whoa!
- You know that is probably, you know,
I just said it for the
first time this clear,
I see D rock in the
background making notes.
I might not have something better
to say right now than that.
That more than half the people that
commented on my content in 2009,
made snarky comments that I should
stay in my lane,
that I'm just the wine guy
and I think that would
be very good advice for
a lot of people cause I know for a fact,
cause I get so many DMs,
the amount of people
who'd no longer want to be
posting what they're posting on Instagram,
but because they were funny and a comedian
but now they're a serious business person.
They used to be a model
but now they want to talk about
their Vegan food business.
They used to be a serious business man
but now they want to be a comedian.
There's a lot of peep that
they're scared because
the first time they post something else,
especially people that are attractive.
I feel a lot of empathy towards people who
are attractive.
They, they, they're self worth and
their likes come from
being attractive then
they try to make one
post about something else
and it doesn't get as many likes and
they feel insecure and
they'd rather get likes than be happy.
Which is crazy.
So, my biggest advice is,
number one is self awareness.
Number two, make.
- Make it.
- Make.
- Mmmhmm.
- Everyone's thinking.
They're working towards it.
They're looking for their videographer.
All these bullshit excuses to not make.
People come up with a hundred excuses.
- They're losing time and losing time.
- They're insecure, they're scared.
They deep down don't think
they can achieve what
they're saying they gonna achieve and
so they're not making.
Number three is patience.
- Yeah.
- I cannot understand
how people think that in
a week or in a month or even in a year,
they're gonna be so famous and so rich and
it's, uh, delusional and so,
patience.
- [Woman] So, uh, my question is uh,
which is the most ordinary thing in
your life that brings you uh,
more joy?
You can bring there, like,
extraordinary energy.
- This is a very funny question.
I don't know how much
garage sale-ing there's
done in Brazil but...
Do you know what a garage sale is?
- Garage sale?
- Do you know when you
go to somebody's yard...
- Uh huh.
- ...and yes.
- And just sell stuff.
- Mmmhmm.
- That is by far the
most ordinary thing that
brings me the most joy.
I think it's the thrill of the hunt.
You know, you pull up and
you don't know what's gonna be there.
It's about knowledge.
There's things that I
know are worth money on
Ebay that other people
don't and sometimes,
I remember this one.
A couple months ago we
went to a German's house.
He had a huge collection of two thousand
Olympic pins.
- 36, 37, 38, 39, 40, 41
pins on the first thing.
He wanted a dollar a piece.
I paid twenty for the whole thing.
And boom.
- Okay, oh that's nice.
- It was very cool.
We bought it for like forty dollars and
it was worth two thousand dollars.
- Oh okay.
- And the high, and the just,
it's a very simple thing.
Go, go wake up at six
o'clock in the morning and
go garage sale-ing but I think,
it speaks to who I am which is,
I love business.
- Mmmhmm.
- I love the thrill of the hunt.
I love the process.
I like that stuff so that would be it.
(upbeat tempo music)
- Here for Brazilian audience,
- Awesome.
- In the stories,
so to any kind of...
- Yup, I got it.
- ...culture you have to
the Brazilian audience,
we just published a video for you for...
- Is this, is the Brazil page?
- Yes, yes Brazil page.
- [Man Off Camera]
Portuguese page actually.
- Portuguese page...
- Yeah.
- ...that's right.
What's up everybody, it's Gary V.
I'm so fired up to be in Brazil about to
take the stage.
I made a huge commitment.
A huge idea right now.
I am gonna learn how to speak Portuguese.
I'm kidding, I'm kidding.
I have no ability to do that.
- Thank you, G.
(Gary laughs)
- [Man In Black Shirt]
What's everyone waiting for?
- [Man] Gary.
- [Gary] Yes sir.
- [Man] You have a,
voiceover in Brazil have
a change in location.
- [Gary] Yes.
- Okay. I very appreciate
you stay here with me.
Okay?
- Thank you so much.
Gary...
- What's up everyone?
- Gary V. I am motivation voice...
- Jesus.
- ...this is the man.
- This is the best voice
I ever fucking heard.
It was amazing.
(men laughing)
- What up guys?
Uh, sitting back stage here in Brazil,
about to give a key note and uh,
posted on Facebook and on Twitter,
for that matter,
the worst complaints you've heard.
Put out some content about complaining,
which I think is a
really vulnerable state,
and then asked people
to leave comments with
the worse complaints they've heard.
Here are some of the ones that the
team thought were funny so,
I'm gonna read 'em,
this is the first time I'm reading 'em.
Here we go.
Number one,
my mom didn't wake me up for work.
This is a 24 year old.
(laughing)
This is gonna be a funny video.
Like just the thought.
First of all,
my mom didn't wake me up for work,
was a terrible excuse in
1984 because you know,
relying on your mom to
be at work is ludicrous.
In 2019, it's fucking absurd.
You've alarms on phone.
Like, like, excuse.
Next.
A few weeks ago my coworker
complained that there
was too much bacon in
his breakfast burrito.
(laughing)
Um, you know,
I'm not sure this was a heavy com-...
I want to know the tone.
I can't imagine somebody
getting super angry,
that being said,
one of things I've been
telling my team about is
one of the reasons I'm
empathetic to my trolls,
to those heavy negativity is,
if you're that sad that you're
putting out venom against
another human being,
you're probably hurting inside and
so if this person was
actually complaining about
too much bacon in their burrito,
what I'm really thinking about is
what's actually going
on in their lives that
that could trigger you?
Too much bacon in a
burrito triggering means
a lot of sadness deep down inside.
Number three,
I heard someone complain on a cruise that
their cookie was too soft.
I mean,
that's just the same
answer as number three.
I don't know if there's
anything else to say.
Number four,
I can't catch a break.
That's an interesting one.
After telling me they are
almost all caught up on
all their Netflix shows.
That's a really good one Brian.
I, I think, you know,
nobody's giving me a
job, all my bosses suck,
I can't catch a break,
the system is rigged,
all loser talk for people that
tend to not want to do action.
Non-motivated because
they haven't found their
passion or they haven't
found a happiness soon
or they grew up in an
entitled environments where
everything was paid for so
they don't even know how to go and get it.
I will always, always repeat this.
When you're overfed
it's hard to be hungry.
And so let's make sure we balance it.
Either you're insecure
or you're entitled and
both are dangerous.
Complaining is the tell to unhappiness.
Stop fucking complaining
and start creating solutions.
(muffled voice over loud speaker)
- Hey guys.
So D Rock's innovating,
which I appreciate D Rock good idea,
posted this 21 minutes ago,
50,000 views really solid good start.
More importantly,
you probably see this is
probably now the third,
one, two, three, four,
third video that we've
put out that, fourth,
that is incorporating a meme video that's
doing well on Instagram and then
layering our two cents on it, you know,
and someone just post in the video,
we put our own kind of take on it and
then I put something in the top.
This one's love to learn
adversity instead of
fearing it.
What's really interesting
about this post is
quite long copy, you know,
because it was, you know,
a video where I'm not speaking or it's not
me context, DJing really matters and
the way I can DJ, add
my two cents to this,
like any great EDJ and
EDM in deep house and
anything of that nature,
they're adding their element so that
you don't feel like it's
just a Rihanna song,
right?
And so what you can do
on social networks is
add a lot of copy and
this is where people who
are great at words,
that might not be as great at videos,
have a way to shine.
You might actually be a better DJ than
a songwriter.
Original content is like songwriting but
adding a lot of sentences to take your
observation or how you
see something that's
already in the zeitgeist,
is a great form of DJing.
A lot of people razz on
DJs for taking hits and
just adding to it but I
think we all figured out
over the last twenty years,
that was a skill set and an art that
we ended up enjoying and
so for me that's the
insight on this post and
I hope that brings you value.
- [Man] Yeah.
- Awesome.
- [Man] That's a wrap.
- [Man In Gray Sweater] Nice to meet you.
- Real pleasure bro.
- I don't do source or DJ dude so
I don't know what's the deal with this?
- It's my favorite number.
- Okay. Why?
- I was taken so,
that happened when I
was five itself like...
- Yeah?
- Five, yeah at five I decided my
favorite number was gonna be five.
- And it stuck.
- And it fucking stuck.
- Imagine if you switched every year.
That'd be confusing.
- I know.
You're like 43 mother fuckers.
(laughing)
And it stuck and then like five...
- I though it was like a...
- ...three years ago I
was taking so many selfies
and I was like man,
I'm just gonna fucking do the,
I just...
- Just throw a five each time.
- ... did it once and I did it twice and
it just stuck and now there's like,
it's really funny like,
now once in a while I see people do it in
the wild and like just without...
- When on safari you seen 'em out there.
- ...anything to do with me.
Yeah dude.
- [Man] I can blame myself.
I do that.
- You do it?
- [Man] I just saw you.
- Yeah. It's so flattering.
It's so cool. So cool.
- I thought it was like
Jets or Landers or some shit.
- It, you know what's funny?
It weirdly is a little bit.
- You grew up with Jets?
- So five, my mom, Pat
Leahy when I was a kid...
- Oh back in the day.
- ...but my mom decided
to knit me a sweater,
because we couldn't
afford a Jet, a jersey,
with like, both, you know,
my most prized possession,
I talk about it a lot.
Like when I buy them,
I want to put it in the
entrance of the stage,
like, it's my thing right?
Cause we couldn't afford a fucking shirt.
- Yeah.
- So my mom made me one and she asked me
what number and I said five.
And so...
- That's cool man.
- ...it does have a little of that.
It is cool.
It's like when something actually
means something to you...
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- ...instead of like,
not actually meaning something.
- Yes you can say that.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- That's awesome.
- Hello, my friend.
How are you?
- How are you?
- I'm very well.
How are you?
- I'm fine.
I'm going to be your voice...
- Thank you.
- ...in Portuguese.
- Do you know how to say fuck?
- I have done work.
- Then we're, then this is all set!
- [Man] How do you say it when you say it?
- Uh, well it depends on the context.
- Fair enough.
- I've been watching a lot of your videos.
- Thank you, thank you.
Anything I can answer for you?
- Anything, what is the...
- I don't know.
- ...you have no idea.
- No.
- You just think?
- It's gonna be a bit malashing,
it's gonna be in that range.
- All right, how bout speed?
How fast do you normally speak?
- I'm a fast fa-
- Fast, fast talker.
- You, you saw?
You've seen the videos?
Like that.
You want me to try to slow it down a hair?
- If you can.
- I'm gonna, I'm gonna truly try.
I don't know if I can
but I will really try.
Getting prepped.
First time in the country which
I'm really excited about.
Gonna give this whole
speech in Portuguese.
Which is unprecedented D Rock.
I'm more worried about D Rock making this
flight then...
- [Announcer] Gary V!
- [Gary] I'm not flying down here to
tell you a get quick rich move.
There is no hack.
There's no fucking shortcut.
It doesn't exist.
When it does,
it lasts for 11 months and then it's over.
The only thing you need to chase,
is figure out what the
fuck you want to sell that
you believe in.
That you believe in.
And the second you understand that,
you gotta figure out how you're gonna
tell the world about the
product you believe in.
Words, videos, audio and then
start making and getting very patient.
Slow.
Slow
The number one thing I love is slow.
The number one thing
that most people hate,
is slow.
That's the fucking game.
Thank you Brazil.
(crowd cheering)
- You got one?
Right here?
D Rock's gonna miss his flight.
It was a good talk.
- [Man In White] Thank you Gary.
- Hi.
Stand up.
What's that?
- Speaking. Speaking Portuguese.
- Ah fuck.
Got it.
(bright upbeat music)